what does a good writing day look like
good writing D looks like I get up and
I've had a successful previous day
writing and I've left it the script at a
point where I feel that I've done my
work yesterday so I'm not feeling guilty
or bad or like or under pressure and I
can just start up again and you know get
my work done in the morning I mean you
know emails and all these other things
and just work and then take lunch and
then come back and you know maybe five
six o'clock wrap it up now that depends
on how many pages a day I have to do and
as I say many days are good solid days
and other days are not so good and not
every scene is gonna be you know on the
level and then there's other days where
it's magical where you you blow through
a sequence and you you write two days in
one day
so you're ahead of the game so it varies
while you're in it but but it is kind of
gonna say scary but once that you know
the starting gun goes and you look at
the I always look at the calendar
because of my due date and I've agreed
and then like on the last assignment
we had an interaction for some other
reason about another project with them
and I said oh by the way I'm on target
to turn it in on Monday and they say oh
thanks you know and they didn't bug me
the whole time they're not sniffing
around saying hey are you you know
because they know I'm not trying to you
know pat myself on the back but they
know because I've worked with them
before and they know that they don't
have to be sending that like how's it
going you know email at being a Nancy
they just leave me alone which is great
place to be you know so good writing day
is like I said having a good now again
the day was crappy before you know you
get up and you you you do it again you
know what I mean just it's a day after
day and it's amazing what you can
accomplish in a month I mean you know
you've been people think oh this big
ordeal about writing a script you know
it's gonna take me six months it's like
maybe but if you structure your time
properly and I do have the time because
my job you structure your time properly
two pages a day you know
you'll have something finished and and
that's it's just doing it and most
people don't do it you know that's the
thing why what do you think they don't
do it I don't know it's I mean a lot of
its fear maybe a lot of its I'll get to
it tomorrow and there's always something
else to do and it's difficult and so if
you're writing something you don't
really care about you know why you're
gonna go back to it and just be like oh
and if you're not getting paid
that's another I don't say great
incentive but when you're getting paid
and you sign a contract that's that
kicks your butt you know into high gear
rather than just but you have to that's
what I'm saying when you write in your
specs you have to treat it as as that
it's lights like a second day job it is
if you just and I'm not saying you have
to do 10 pages a day but if you do two
pages today and like when I was working
at the law firm for two years at lunch I
would write I would write by hand but I
wanted to like not just sit there and be
like uh you know I was so every day at
lunch that was an hour that's five hours
a week including the time at night you
know it's doable if you just plant it to
plant it out you know so you're looking
at the due date then you're looking at
how many pages and then you're putting
sort of a red X on a calendar and you're
basically doing how many pages a day
well it depends on what I'm given you
know but this last job I worked in I was
three pages a day which was was your
luxury
that's not normal right that's right I
mean three to five three five yeah the
really the really hard scripts are eight
to ten when it's a short period like a
rewrite or it's like we need this in two
weeks
whoa you know you hang up the phone
you're like okay you know and like this
year I've you're always learning I'd be
glad to become a faster writer not that
I'm a slow writer but I would take my
time you know but not as fast as and I
knew if I was going to be taking more
jobs I would have to be a faster writer
and what would I just do that on my own
I was forced to do that
by challenging myself you know which i
think is very important to always
challenge yourself and many times we
don't challenge ourselves unless we come
up against something which challenges us
and so that was a particulars I did the
job and then I was like oh wow okay and
I knew I could do it but at first I
didn't think I could do it and so I went
back to my old techniques and it's funny
sometimes I forget them and someone says
to me you know you should buy this book
and you really go yeah and they start
talking about it I go oh you mean my
book and they go yeah you've forgotten
your disciplines I go you're right you
know I mean it's like oh yeah you're
right you got it you know it's funny but
yeah that's incidentally just to throw
this in there your book is now at the
Santa Monica library which is where you
know yes high school I used to work
there as a page which is shelving books
it was a nice clean job you know and so
now it's for how ironic that years later
and my book is at the library that I
used to work at you know and I had to go
in the other day of for copies it's
pretty cool yeah that's pretty cool and
it's right next to you know there's John
McKee and and Truby and and you know
screenwriting for dummies and then
there's my book I'm like wow dude double
take and and it's been checked out you
know but since they've got it's been out
you know people checking it out so it's
good and you came across that by
accident I went in there and then yeah
it was they have some of my DVDs of
movies that I've written you know and
you know they order things however and
so it was cool because it's nice that
people can access it and then maybe you
know it's a kind of book that is not
just a read and one time it's you can go
back to it many times I think that's how
I wrote it where you can you know pick
it off the shelf and look at the
particular things I'm going through this
problem you know and maybe it would help
you with that type of thing that's how I
wanted to write it was the fact that you
could it's something you would keep you
know next to your computer and you could
go you know some books you read once and
that's it
you know it's uh it's about all these
things I've been talking about but
surviving you know in the trenches as a
writer or living a writer's life
you